dying light 2 could take you up to 500
hours to 100 completed take two bot
zynga for 12.7 billion dollars and more
players will need to spend about 500
hours to fully complete dying light too
developer teclan has confirmed while
also acknowledging that this is the
projected run time for a 100 run
according to our internal qa testing it
takes about 500 hours to see everything
the game offers find every collectible
listen to every dialogue fetch every
easter egg finish every possible ending
and visit every corner of the world
techlin said we are fortunate to have a
very passionate community of fans who
have been returning to the original
dying light throughout the last seven
years and we know they can't wait to
truly lose themselves in our latest work
a focused playthrough of the game's main
story can be finished in about 20 hours
depending on your play style that play
time gets bumped up to about 80 hours
including all side quests and then of
course 500 hours including everything
else dying light 2 launches on february
4th for ps5 xbox series x and s and will
also be available via the cloud for
nintendo switch the game is also coming
to ps4 xbox one and pc
grand theft auto company take 2 is
acquiring farmville company zynga for
12.7 billion the company announced on
monday morning this is a combined cash
and stock deal importantly the deal has
not closed and there is a go shop
provision where baizinga has 45 days to
look for a better deal with a different
company many may recall how take 2 was
originally lined up to acquire code
masters before ea came in and bought the
company instead in a news release take 2
said this is a transformative
combination of companies that makes take
2 one of the largest and most
diversified mobile game publishers in
the industry while also mentioning the
acquisition is a strategic combination
that brings together take two's console
and pc franchises and a mobile
publishing platform they went on to say
we are incredibly excited to have found
a partner in take two that shares our
commitment to investing in our players
further stating we begin a new journey
which allows us to create even better
games reach larger audiences and achieve
significant growth as a leader in the
next era of gaming then in a slide deck
take two said it sees a clear path for
bringing take two's console and pc games
to mobile thanks in part to the zynga
deal it did not however name any
specific titles we've had gta on mobile
before so does this mean gta 5 or online
or next
while we've caught glimpses at elden
rings gameplay from its closed network
tests one thing we haven't been able to
see is its character creator in action
however thanks to a video uploaded to
youtube today we finally get to see what
kind of characters beautiful or not
players will be able to make in the
upcoming from software title eldon
ring's closed network tests never
intentionally let players access the
character creator instead players were
given five pre-made characters to pick
from the reason behind that choice is
obvious after seeing a video of the
character creator in action the menu is
clearly unfinished with most of its text
missing along with some other character
models while eldon ring's character
creation menu is by no means in a
finished state it does provide a good
look at the game's improved character
models a majority of the basic options
look decently realistic sporting
impressively rendered hair but of course
all of that changes once the player
decides to mess with the game's numerous
facial sliders aside from their
difficulty from software's games are
known for their deep character creation
menus players can customize numerous
features of their character's face like
how far their jawline extends the size
of their cheekbones and so on in the
right hands this menu can be used to
create impressive original characters or
recreations of others so what is your
go-to character that you like to create
let me know in the comments and be sure
to like and subscribe so you don't miss
your next episode of gamespot news we'll
see you later
[Music]